this week on forward we have me jules
turpak hosting and we speak with
comedian ryan long about comedy of
course today's political climate our
relationship with work and much more
this week on forward
[Music]
[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to ford my
name is jules turpak you may have turned
into an episode with me uh zach or yang
in the past but today i'm actually
leading i'm here with ryan long who i'm
going to intro in just a second but if
you haven't tuned into an episode with
me on it before i definitely want to
give a quick background because this is
definitely a change from when zach
or yang are leading so i'm a cultural
commentator predominantly on tick tock
i've grown my platform to 250k on there
i'm mostly focused on tech and digital
culture but in reality today digital
culture funnels into every aspect of
life and on that platform i often uplift
ideas like ubi and independent politics
because i think it's an important aspect
of our future
so that's kind of the role i play in all
of this but and how i fit in here but
today's guest is ryan long comedian i
would say cultural commentator as well
do you like ever deem yourself as so no
i would just say comedian nailed it the
first time god okay just comedian um
you're actually the first comedy show
i've ever been to which one i went to
the stand it was like when you were
actually recording your special you came
on the special table yes yes that was
very nice
yeah it was i was like scared because i
didn't want to be like singled out like
i was just in the back i was like i hope
like you you know like with yeah stand
up stuff um but i was in the back and i
was like you want to end up in like a
comedian destroys heckler compilation
yeah the yeah exactly that and but i was
in the corner so i was like this is i
feel like prime spot if someone's just
in the very far back corner for you to
be like hey you back there yeah luckily
you didn't i don't do a ton of crowd
stuff yeah yeah i feel like you didn't
at all like one of your like uh people
who went before you was doing it a lot
and i was like oh god yeah but i think
that a lot of comedians do crowd work
was uh
you know right now how how long does it
take to put together an hour of comedy
yeah you know a long time and how long
does it take together put together an
hour of crowd work one hour yeah the
go-to question is always what do you do
for work yeah yeah yeah always that's
the host stuff is there any bachelorette
parties in the area yeah that's hosting
stuff i don't even really know what i
would say for that but aside from comedy
you also host the boys cast podcast with
your friend danny how do you pronounce
his last name paulus check okay cool i
mean
and how long have you guys known each
other how did you meet for a long time
he's a comic from toronto too so we both
kind of moved here at the same time and
like i mean finding a
a good dynamic for someone as a podcast
host is like definitely difficult for
the long term he's also often on your
youtube channel me and me and dan have
been doing stuff forever together so
yeah i came from toronto and i was doing
a lot of this stuff for a really long
time over there and when i came to
america i just kind of did all the same
stuff but here yeah so wait that's
awesome so he was in toronto with you
yeah he's also canadian so i moved here
he moved here like three months later or
whatever uh kind of slacked on and then
i figured everything out yeah um you
came in the beginning of the pandemic
right yeah like maybe four months before
right that's
no it wasn't here for very long before
they shut it down yeah that's
terrible timing i know but yeah no so i
basically to be honest it kind of feels
like i was thinking about this last week
where i was like i basically oh it took
me about two years to kind of get my
life back in america the way it was in
canada but it's just bigger now because
it's america oh 100 and you've done
traditional media stuff too did you do
that and what was that well i did uh
i've done a few like tv shows and stuff
like that but probably before i was
moving here i was doing digital for a
long time so i i this tv show the cbc
canadian broadcast socialist comedy
network uh
and it was um
i did maybe three seasons of this show
called trontopia and then i did a show
there called that guy i was doing digi
like those digital sketches very similar
to what i was doing now my the old tv
shows were kind of like on the street
like allergy stuff which i still do a
lot of that and then the best yeah tom
green was like kind of the guy for like
me and my friends growing up and then i
was doing digital sketches and i there
and this website called the hard times
that i helped build up which is like a
satire site so i was doing a lot of that
kind of stuff but it was always about
specific i was doing stuff about kind of
toronto and canada culture and you know
kind of party culture and the scene and
stuff and then i was doing the same
thing about you know music stuff and
which is all kind of par uh
you know worlds i was in and then when i
moved here i was kind of doing it about
you know current culture which i think
at the time i would say that current
culture and politics were very like
intertwined of course so yeah i mean you
hit all aspects of culture really well
but um definitely most of your top
viewed youtube videos have to do with
politics i think i thought some of them
yeah i have a few to be honest my top
viewed ones
uh are my biggest video ever is a is a
more like standard guy girl stuff on the
street yeah yeah but then i was just
gonna say that one because yeah yeah
when i went to your profile i was like
okay the woke and racist one is
definitely top and then it was that that
was no this one's bigger that one's
actually not the biggest there's that's
the thing about youtube
there is the videos that
really kind of what you're saying like
influence culture where it almost you
know someone sometimes will do something
you know south park would always be like
this where they would do a bit or an
episode and then moving forward you
couldn't like you you'd have to build on
that if you ever wanted to make that
same point you'd have to kind of be like
well south park did their version of
this and simpsons had a lot of that
stuff too where it essentially changes
the dynamics of culture but then there
are these things you know there's people
on youtube operating where it's like you
wouldn't even you go who is that guy i
don't even know his name and you go yeah
he does a hundred million views in an
episode you know there's these huge
people on the internet that it's just
slightly outside of culture i always
think you know there's kind of actors in
hollywood or whatever then there's
television then there's sort of
uh comedians then there's like
podcasters youtubers then there's like
streamers then there's sort of like the
streamers on alternative platforms
yeah yeah yeah and a lot of them have
these huge audiences but no one knows
about it yeah i mean because everyone's
pocket of the internet yeah with the
algorithms like people yeah like you're
saying have millions and i'm like i've
never seen them but they're on like my
friend's algorithms constantly but yeah
there's an ecosystem yeah for sure and
for people to have context to your
youtube channel yeah you're doing a lot
of sketches um
a lot of different camera angles they're
not kind of like one go and the top
video we were talking about it was how
to break a man most honest girl ever and
i think it like now it's posted as a
short because it's less than a minute
right yeah yeah no that whatever did
like across platforms like i don't know
30 million views or something like
that was just is i don't even want to
know like that's real correct yeah oh
look so i have this thing on tv i just
dude that was just standard man on the
street stuff like i i really did come up
you know doing the
i don't know if you know what i call it
pranks like man on the street bothering
people and a lot of my early stuff was
like me you know getting kicked out of
places and just doing that stuff and
then when i moved here i i kind of said
i was like i don't really know people
here i don't really have a crew you know
you spent this entire life building like
a network and we had a studio in toronto
and all this sort of stuff right so when
i moved here i was like okay i know what
i can do
very easily is this on the street stuff
because i just need a camera and a mic
so that's why i started doing that stuff
because i'm like i don't know anyone
yeah well lately i went back to my roots
yeah
so on tick tock though i recently found
someone who's like they did kind of on
the street stuff it's more wholesome
type of content but i figured out that
they stayed yo what's your body count yo
yeah but they staged so much of it i was
like oh god okay but anyway this video
staging's wild because yeah i mean for
starters the whole
positive part about that art form is
art form but you know what i mean that
genre of making no it's an art yeah to
be entertaining i mean anything that
yeah i guess it can be an art form i
mean i i kind of study it i mean i think
the technical thing is like the art of
like clowning yes
yeah right but um the whole thing is
it's the easiest one so you go you know
what i could go
out for a day and make a ton of videos
and if you're good at it it's kind of
the same as crowd work it's easier right
so if i was to say okay well if i'm
going to interview 10 people it's like
what now i have 10 actors
i guess i guess you could go find people
on the street and be like hey can i give
you money to say this it's like that is
disgusting to me like that's the
equivalent of having like a plant and a
you know doing crowd work and having
plants in the audience yeah like to me
that i just i guess every you know i
feel like the internet has no rules you
know the same way that people like meme
guys feel no ways about stealing content
they're just like what it's the
internet's joke
yeah yeah yeah well they just don't see
it they see the whole world very
differently right whereas i think to me
coming from like doing that stuff that'd
just be like insane like it feels like a
moral boundary like to take so much fun
what are you doing this is crazy no it
is crazy and like um on that video too
when you because you do a lot of street
interviews do people ever reach out and
like can you take that yeah a lot uh no
yeah not a lot a lot but it does happen
yeah probably
i don't know 20 times because they
probably don't realize like your
audience no
no means by that yeah and sometimes they
i have taken a few things down
um and generally it depends on
what the
context was and what their reason was
so you won't like is it ever only
content that you take down no public
bachelor backlash stuff it's only that
involves other people that you end up
the only time i've ever taken anything
down yeah is generally if i if it's like
old and i actually didn't like it or
whatever or some version of here be
example there was this girl
that did a video
um
it was about like pedophiles right
and she didn't even look that stupid but
i basically was saying
like i was trying to get them to argue
against the idea that a good way to get
rid of pedophiles is like how your dad
makes you smoke a pack of cigarettes to
get rid of smoking like what if we got
all the pedophiles just have sex with so
many kids that they got sick of it and
whatever i was she was flipping and she
was plus yeah and she was
[Laughter]
well that's whenever you talk about any
that's why when we talk about art form
any all of this stuff is so silly and
then when you put yourself in like a
kind of like a yeah right now we're like
you know podcasting situation and you
talk about the type of garbage that
we're making right but i think the you
know whatever the art is to try to get
people in these like moments and that's
like the i guess from the technical
thing you'd be like to try to trap
someone in the right like improv game
whether they can't leave or whatever but
anyways she was like i work with kids as
a job and i work with underprivileged
kids and i'm very like worried that this
thing's gonna and then i didn't really
even see that and then she came to my
show she was so stressed out about it
and she's like i'm applying for this job
and this video she was arguing against
it so i don't even know but she was just
so stressed out about it and she wasn't
even being a jerk about it she was just
like and i was just like yeah it's
understanding whatever it's fine i just
said yeah no problem
and these times it's more important than
ever that we save money wherever we can
particularly if you're running a small
business and one great way to do this is
stamps.com you can get exclusive
discounts and rates that will save your
business money we're talking about 30
off us postal service rates and up to 86
off ups do not find yourself stuck in
line at the post office ever again
stamps.com is like a post office on your
computer you can save money save time
and focus on the things that actually
matter to you whether it's in your
business or in your personal life so
start mailing and shipping with
stamps.com today
keep more money in your pocket where it
belongs sign up with promo code yang and
a special offer that includes a
four-week trial plus free postage and a
digital scale no long-term commitments
or contracts just go to stamps.com click
the microphone at the top of the page
and enter code yang stamps.com the post
office of the future
[Music]
so your second most viewed video is the
one that you definitely always get like
called on for is when wokes and racists
actually agree on everything and a lot
of your content is kind of going on both
sides of the extremes i'm interested
like what is usually i think so that's
why i like you guys i think i was
talking about you know somewhat similar
perspective of how the world works yeah
yeah like i think kind of yeah hitting
all angles
whether it's two sides whether it's like
five sides of it um so usually when you
are getting comments on these videos
is there a lot of backlash because you
are kind of equally often hitting both
sides of the spectrum yeah but well as
you know i think that there was a moment
where hitting both sides was a you know
an admission of being on one side right
that's kind of how they saw it
um
but
yeah but it depends on what you know it
depends on what you like consider
backlash right so there was a while
where it was very
we're going to try to get you fired from
your jobs and sponsors and all that but
i was
pretty early on when i moved here i knew
that i was in my opinion moving away
from being part of the industry and
moving into a scenario where i was
trying to design my life that i couldn't
have it all take it away yep so if i if
i got a lot you know it'd be it would
i've there's one sometimes you know
there'll be like mass flagging campaigns
everyone's mad at you people post these
videos this guy's bad and then everyone
tries to flag all your stuff and that
would suck if you just got deleted and
those things suck right and that's part
of like kind of internet culture right
now but
i think the if i was to say oh i did all
this stuff and i lost sponsors or i lost
this i would kind of now rejig my brain
of okay i'm now i have like these
pressure points that can be hit here so
i'm trying to design
a life that i could you know be a
comedian that i don't have to always
think about am i gonna get in trouble
for this so i can just try to make the
stuff that i think is funny and i think
that's the people that are doing the
best right now if i look at if you look
at this like moment in time and you go
who's actually making the best stuff
where it doesn't feel like they're
what do people want or what am i not
going to get in trouble for they
actually looking at the pulse and the
energy and trying to be like what would
be the funniest thing like in actually
just doing it from you know like a pure
trying to be great standpoint i think if
i looked at all those things it directly
corresponds with the people that have
designed their life that they can't have
it taken away from them yeah because
that
that pressure's so strong and it's you
can pretend it doesn't creep into your
brain what it does oh 100 and like for
that video um again for everyone it has
like six million views it's called when
woke and racist actually agree on
everything definitely check it out
what was like the process for it because
i mean it was just like gold and was it
kind of over a few weeks obviously just
like observing current culture or did
you guys just sit down you and danny sit
down together and just i write the
videos but that was honestly got just
another video for me
it was never supposed to yeah like you
didn't think it wasn't any intentional
no there's the odd time that i've
predicted it but i i think that i
haven't talked about that one yeah that
was a while ago but i think the
the original thing was just i remember
you know whatever i had this joke about
uh
the way that they would kind of classify
people i remember even when i was in
toronto and then being like you know
having the separate comedy shows for
races and stuff like that and then
whatever there was a there was a few
things that were happening kind of at
that moment that i think that that was
why i made that that week but i never
thought it was gonna i was doing a lot
of these two shirt videos but i think
that's a perfect idea of a video
that
what we talked about that that was like
a moment where not as you know over blow
it or whatever but i've had a few things
that i've said that i feel like did
influence the way that at least you know
comics which are part of the ecosystem
that other people look at where
uh someone that i uh
really liked he goes yeah you did a i
liked that video because it was kind of
like oh cool we don't be mad about that
anymore someone said it was just like
someone said the thing and then you can
kind of move on but so for me i was like
i i then i i kind of wouldn't say that
again now so when i look at that now i
little bit think like if i saw someone
make a version of that video now i'd be
like duh like
so you kind of uh when you influence the
thing it kind of just gets in there and
then your own points become hack i think
that's if you look at so many uh
comedians or bands or whatever that had
like a very specific style to change the
world
i think the most egregious example of
that would be jerry seinfeld where
him doing stand-up the way that he
invented which changed the course of
stand-up seems like a person doing an
impression of stand-up comedy that's
true so if he comes up and he's like
what's the d and he go oh this guy's
like doing an impression of comedy he's
like yep but i invented it but you say
you sort of i feel strongly about moving
away from my own things as soon as they
get popular yeah and like for a lot of
your videos too you've gotten like media
outreach and i feel like it tends to be
right-leaning ones that ask you to come
on which is interesting in the way that
because what you were saying earlier
when you typically come at both sides i
feel like it's typically the the left
that tends to put you in a box of oh you
know you need to pick a side like oh
you're a centrist it's like no and i
think you said this in an interview
you're like i'm just not playing the
game like yeah at all
so like what has happened dynamic been
like in terms of like
yeah
when you are making fun of watch i mean
yeah the the
the right tries to use people for their
message the same way the left tries to
use people for their message right you
know
it's fun to make fun of but you'll see
you know these uh
these articles being you know
like comedy central on places like this
will do this a lot where they'll take a
left-wing comedian and be like
this you know muslim uh trans
uh non-binary anxiety it's changing the
way comedy works and you'll have to deal
with it and everyone's like yo [ __ ] this
girl this isn't even you know what i
mean but she didn't necessarily ask for
that she just did this
thing and then the comedy central was
kind of like if you don't think she's
great then you know
f you right so it's sort of and then
this person becomes the poster child for
their message and the right is very into
that as well but you know that these uh
things are constantly changing right so
the
political movements are always going to
be tried political movements are
inherently moralizing
and
whenever uh
the moralizing on the other side is more
popular i feel like that becomes the the
strong telling you what to do side which
obviously was more the left in the last
four years so naturally any dissonance
are gonna step away from the person is
telling you what to do because it's i
think inherently uh
oil and water with creating funny and
good things you know any strict code of
conduct that you can't step outside is
obviously gonna be
your natural instinct is to challenge it
if you're trying to be doing anything in
art that's at least relevant to you know
uh culture so then
when that happens you start and then
everyone that's against that they start
being like look these guys agree with us
because i think that comedians and
people that you know at least build
themselves as
one partisan it's like more appealing
for them to be like look this guy's on
her side but the part that happens next
is they don't say you know look at these
guys they're moralizing then the other
people say yeah and this is what should
happen and then i think that's when then
the artists start to leave them you know
yeah because most of the time yeah you
go everyone's a lot of times everyone
agrees at pointing something out wrong
but then they have very different uh
diagnosis of what should happen now
or what she replace it yeah and it's an
interesting conversation because you
talked about earlier how you've been
trying to kind of move into your own
thing that way no one can break it down
like no i could take my life away yeah
no one can take your life away and i'm
interested to hear your experience
between yeah traditional media and what
you do now mostly on youtube and like
i'm sure obviously you you feel very
strong in your individual endeavors more
so now than in past years yeah and like
there's the whole conversation right now
about free speech and regardless like if
you're working with a team that is
overhead of you in traditional media
there are those external pressures with
different things you can and cannot say
like how has your experience been both
like monetarily and like sustaining
yourself and also just like in terms of
like liberation being able to like do
this all on your own now with youtube
and everything
yeah i would i was doing stuff in the
thick of
things getting wild right so you know it
was
everyone at these companies was fighting
this too right it's not like
when you go to these big businesses they
have a lot of people that just were into
comedy that like have this job that
they're not happy about it either so
although i would have a lot of
conversations of people being like for
example when i was doing my show it'd be
you know things like the fact that i'm
like white and uh like a dude and
straight or whatever and i was like the
director of the show and this and that
why it was such a hard sell right so i
had like a very popular show and it
would be like you know the amount of
conversations and people being like dude
you're a number one show i'm like the
biggest fan but it's like there's no
okay let me try to sell this and we
package stuff and be like there's no way
i could sell this internally with like a
white male lead like is there any way
that we could and just it would just be
constantly these kind of conversations
about uh you know and
it's not like you could just
point any individual places just what
society was doing and what they were
doing but on top of that
the um
when you're doing digital sketches
you having a uh two month window
where you have to you know put all these
you sell your thing here are 10 ideas if
we're doing then we kind of sell this
you know then we kind of have uh
a bunch of
people that kind of go through them and
make notes then we shoot it then we edit
it then we have someone make notes takes
out like so much person out like
like
yeah authenticity from the beginning of
it so i remember even little things like
for example i remember kind of being
part of that mainstream machine
and
doing sketches where
a month later
we would i would edit them and then send
them off and i remember getting them
back like three weeks later so now
totally had been six or seven weeks
since we shot and i remember even at the
time
being like
not even culturally the moment had
passed but feeling like now this feels
slow because
the pacing of the internet sped up in
those you know i remember just what felt
right to me at the time two months later
feeling slow
because
even speed wise and energy wise things
have their ebbs and flows right for sure
so i know the obvious thing is we'll
just make you know evergreen content
things that aren't on the pulse but it's
like well
sure but that's not really a good recipe
for making viral sketches like they've
got to have even if they're not
uh
you know about something super specific
they're usually about sort of a
at least a like the energy of culture
right you're catching
even that joke like it has some sort of
context of why it it feels refreshing to
be said at that time right if it's two
months later someone usually got to it
and even one week later someone usually
got to it so not that i love i think we
you know i've talked about potentially
making a movie and i would it is fun to
make a show that isn't culturally you
know like that but the internet's like
that so i think that
they are having a lot of internal
problems about who they're allowed to
select
at the same time that the business
models has a lot of kind of bugs too
yeah and like the original jokes or
whatever like the script that you come
up with it can be like gold but the fact
that people's job is kind of to make
updates and all these things people feel
like they're not doing their job unless
they're being super nitty-gritty about
stuff and then the end product ends up
being [ __ ] because it's like not better
at all yeah dude there was a i think i
think it was college humor that had you
know some crazy amount of employees
right it was it was really rising and
how many people worked there and then i
think they lost all their funding and
essentially like fired most the people
and i think their like revenue and views
didn't change
like you're just like just cut half the
people and nothing changed because so
many people don't need to be there yeah
it's just so i'm always having that uh
debate internally of whether i grow my
team or try to shrink it and make it
more lean yeah
[Music]
there's the news of netflix this week
subscriber loss of 200 000 subscribers
were lost when they meant to grow by
like 2.5
million subscribers i'm pretty sure it
was projections yeah like the
projections and then cnn shut down one
map cnn plus shutdown one month after
launch um yang actually put out a good
tweet about this and i kind of agree
with it there are so many subscriber
based platforms right now and it can be
overwhelming like there are yes there
are a ton of people in the world you can
always find people to support your
content and like whatever but there are
a ton of subscriber based platforms i
think that plays like a role in it for
sure but just in terms of like
the future of entertainment and
everything what do you see that's the
whole situation as with those
subscribers isn't cnn on all day every
day
well yeah like why why do they need a
cnn
you're gonna watch both of them at the
same time
yeah i don't think imagine not you know
the news is on don't they have multiple
channels all day every day and you're
just like i'm not still not getting my
fix i need that extra little interview
i'm saying i actually did a video with
this
on the street was saying that no but
they're they're still three you know
they're still disseminating getting rid
of all the misinformation but there's
still three percent misinformation on
their real site if you go behind the pay
wall that's where there's zero
misinformation they finally got rid of
all the massive information yeah it's
just like final form of cnn yeah and
like
what do you
two just as both as a creator because
like i mean kid kids today are like
that's like a number one job they want
to move into cnn plus no no no
like number one on their list when
they're five years old is cnn plus um no
so i've heard that yeah like um just
being on youtube and everything too and
like monetization there like how how do
you look at the subscription model do
you think that's something that's
sustainable for the long term when all
like the power is going to individuals
everyone's going to have their form of
like obviously needing to sustain
themselves yeah individually online like
kind of what yeah do you have any people
well people well the netflix thing i
think is the same thing we're talking
about where there was um i mean that
that obviously is this description that
is the future of entertainment in a lot
of ways but the uh
they i think a lot of people would it
would be fun to
think the narrative was just like you
know they're
like kind of beholden to the like woke
mob and that's why their content's worse
and whatever but i think that there is
there is obviously some of
i think it's more probably accurate to
be like a lot of companies like that
have a very specific mission and they
were the only player for a long time and
then
as soon as your mission gets a little
wishy-washy all it takes is for you know
and now you now it's like your mission's
a little
less clear
you know you start having side missions
which maybe you know whatever like
activism or you know uh dealing with
your employees and now you have all
these internal fights so well this stuff
is happening which happens everywhere uh
on top of that you have more competitors
uh they're things that pricey
like hbo is making great stuff they're
having like a moment
and so i think it's just now
you know they were in a platform a
period where they were the only one and
they were the best one and they had a
the kind of first mover advantage and
now there's everyone's doing it and you
know in a lot of ways better so it's i
don't think it's so simple as what
happened with netflix but in terms of
you know how people always say that
over and over again in the world they
just
unpackage everything and then repackage
it exactly so
there is something to say about like i
think that right now
the biggest places if you if you look at
who are the probably well known as you
know the biggest comedians for the most
part there was at least a good four or
five year period where they were uh we
won't make stuff with these people and
that's always sort of happened where
there's
the the you know mainstream misses
things whether that's in music that's
the reason why there's a million djs
that are selling at arenas that you
don't hear on the radio and maybe that's
and then now that's sort of starting
because they've sort of figured out a
way to pair those people with pop
singers and that's kind of what the new
version of those people being popular
looked like right but
and they would there's always been a
huge genre of like black comedians that
the industry missed and they still are
missing because you know they have a
very specific window of what they like
so
right now you have a lot of the huge
taste makers that aren't on these
traditional platforms so i think it does
make sense for them to have subscription
models and people want to be part of it
but
it's not unlikely that it's not you know
unlikely or improbable that in five
years a lot of those operate essentially
like record labels and you're starting
to see that sort of uh take place right
so basically i'm a big
i think decentralization is what
happened is happening in all those
industries and
does decentralizations naturally happen
because the internet and then it's also
happen and it's also like in conjunction
with the industry
and mainstream places making bad choices
and making bad decisions and losing
their focus so those things do things
together is positive for i think
decentralization but what happens next
generally probably looks like
uh let's say
you know you have a situation where 10
people all have these big subscription
models well why not package those all
together and now we have so i and then
you essentially
comedians or podcasters or uh
you know news curators essentially
operate like record labels
as opposed to
um
media conglomerates that's interesting
and then i mean i was also confused i
feel like everyone kind of flocks to one
wanting to put yeah a political label in
all these situations to me like i never
felt like netflix was like super woke by
any means but people they produce some
pretty wild stuff and they really you
know and reed hastings is like fairly
active you know with sans you know
getting involved in those what was dave
chappelle's special on that was netflix
well again that was a perfect yeah
that's a perfect example of like if that
was
like if that was uh most comedy networks
there were you know in historically
there probably wouldn't be protests from
your employees but yeah that's true so
that's like a you know they have your
standard kind of silicon valley culture
or whatever where people don't like that
stuff so i mean imagine you're like hey
we wanted to put out a special with the
biggest comedian in the world and you
know probably what a lot of people would
say is the best comedian in the world
and then your
employees are protesting it like
you don't see that as like
uh you can you know and obviously they
decided to hold their ground on this one
but you think they're gonna not think
twice next time they'll go okay well
what about the one level down from that
what if this guy is the biggest comedian
in the world and we want to make a
special with them and it ain't dave
chappelle is that worth the trouble for
us
so i think you end up well then what if
this one's here in terms of the energy
on the pulse but it's not going to cause
us any trouble i mean i think it's it's
not even always sinister it's just like
decisions that naturally happen if
forces forces forces it's like a guy
with a or people in a relationship where
the person's like yo why are you always
out whatever right and you might be like
i don't listen to her if i want to go
i'll go out but eventually four years
from now you're telling me didn't go out
a little less after all this pressure
like if you stay together eventually you
kind of it all seeps in and you're just
naturally people moving in a direction
that makes their life easier unless you
are consciously not unless you
consciously make that your mission
statement where hey we know that this
thing is making us worse so we're
actively pushing against it or actively
making some move like the coinbase guy
did or whatever where you say hey you
know what we're not going to do politics
in the office place and
this hurt was a big kfl in the short
term but we think in the long term it'll
be positive and
i don't know those are the experiments
that are taking place all over right for
sure yeah because you know some people
could say i i'm a big proponent that you
can do one thing at once and even if
like in a week if i'm doing stand-up or
if i'm doing videos like that has to be
three days here four days you know i
don't think that people can do it i want
multiple things at once and i think that
i like that notion yeah and i don't
think companies can do multiple things
at once and if you say we want to be the
best streaming service and the best and
then you get sidetracked with these kind
of other other missions all it takes is
for someone else to do the opposite and
then you see where it ends up and i
think that you're seeing that in like
cities too in uh states right we go
california's running its experiment of
what it's going to look like and then
florida is running its own experiment of
what we want our schools to look like
and what we want this to look like and
you're kind of ending up with these
different places and you can people can
choose which one they like better
yeah i i saw or which one's more
successful is it probably a better way
to look at and then you get to choose
what your definitions of success is if
you if you look at a thing and you go
hey well i you know lean in a situation
where i actually not looking for a place
where people can have more opportunity
what i'm looking for is the least level
of stratification and huge welfare if
you say okay well it's really impossible
to start a company and be an
entrepreneur and
on average people make less money but
there's less uh
uh
stratification or whatever then that
might be a positive for you and then you
go that was a success depends on what
your goal was yeah speaking to schools
literally the past 48 hours there's been
a ton of news coverage on like push back
on just public the public school system
um and just kind of wanting people to
get more choice what is you like what
was your experience in school and like
in in canada and yeah i would just like
to hear did you go to college or yeah i
went to a university yeah oh yeah we
call in canada we college and university
of different things we call university
university and then college will be what
you call community college oh okay yeah
but you call everything in college yeah
college or university yeah i usually
always say college yeah yeah but um yeah
i think in terms of the uh the like yeah
everyone's talking about the school
stuff right now like you know in florida
and everything to me that is uh that's
just a natural progression of like the
moralizing because
as soon as you uh as soon as you start
telling everyone that we have kind of
the moral
uh
you know we have the code of what like
morality is
eventually you're gonna have to defend
that like from first principles so i
think that
other people are now realizing that
that's like an effective political tool
to be moralizing uh
re-realizing what people have known you
know uh probably in the history of time
that
a good way to you know gather momentum
is to moralize so
i mean and it doesn't even mean they're
all true it's like the same reason why i
would say yeah there's a
it's not like i would be like racism is
good
but you know the like extreme moralizing
on you know where every action i think
you go on the other side it's like okay
well i don't i think it's i think that i
can make a pretty good case for why
teaching you know seven-year-olds about
sex is immoral yeah and i think you
could probably get a lot of people on
that side right yeah so i think extremes
yeah well but it's almost like
we are we pretend a lot of times that i
think a lot of people that
or at least want to believe that you can
have arguments on principles and when
you're having intellectual conversations
like how do you not sort of have some
sort of principles if you want to have
any sort of level of uh
coherency yeah right but in that realm
it's like really no one has a problem
being a hypocrite it's not about
principles it's like a war
right so it's uh
it's it's irrelevant if the principles
flipped for most people what's relevant
is like getting your way yeah just
tribalism stuff yeah so it really it
feels like right now you're sort of
it's not about right or left you're
fighting like a uh
here's
two
centralized bodies that sort of tell you
how that would love to in a perfect
world to tell everyone how to live
versus
you know what what is what is a
naturally decentralized future look like
and
that probably will
remain to be seen the extent to which
that emerges and the extent to which
everyone fights back against it
yeah and what platforms are you on are
you like even on facebook and everything
with your content as well facebook's a
hidden uh
yeah i've had a few hits on there but i
know a few people that they're like
that's the hidden secret they're selling
tickets from facebook because they need
good content on there they're like okay
there's still a lot of people yeah yeah
yeah well yeah cause i mean you yeah
especially in other countries yeah i was
gonna say other it's like the main
platform like india that's
all the rage there i know india got like
rid of tick tock and such so i mean like
other platforms are all the rage there
but like what is yeah the different
reaction of your comedy on different
platforms or do you feel like across the
board it's kind of a similar no there
there is i mean you could i think drive
yourself crazy trying to
uh
you know assess
yeah i mean i think one person has
said a while ago that it's like it's
probably best to pick one platform that
you design it for
and then so i do make different cuts for
different platforms and i i feel like
i'm fairly in tune with
the rhythms of different platforms and
the
even just the
you know what becomes popular on there
changes the dynamic of it and it's you
know you'll see people post their
stand-up clips on on tick tock now where
not only do they have words but they
have graphics like it really is like
quick stimulation yeah
yeah yeah yeah and that's the vibe of
you know i mean every platform probably
has the extent of how much they watch
before they turn it off and then there's
also you know what what uh what are the
dimensions and to what extent you put uh
words on the screen and how big are they
and
all of that is a way to keep attention
right but um i think that i
you're always losing somewhere so i
think that uh i try to probably think of
youtube as the main thing so i think i
would consider myself ultimately making
content for youtube yeah and then i clip
it for other platforms yeah
most of your skits are i would say
they're
predominantly under like five minutes
right yeah yeah about like two and a
half yeah okay gotcha and like my rhythm
is kind of like a i make comedy sketches
like punk songs
that's interesting
and like so aside from what you're
posting on the most what platform are
you do are you most active on twitter do
you feel like throughout the day no
really i don't really post on twitter i
only post my videos there and then like
tweet you know maybe once or twice a
week i mean more like as a bystander
like oh like look at it yeah
um no probably if i was being honest i
probably look at instagram the most
because i also use that as like a
messenger to message all my friends like
i have all my group chats on instagram
and i've so i actually
communicate with people on instagram so
that's why i use that yeah it's like
stories on instagram and messaging is
like
all all they seem to like have left
which is really i mean in the us it
feels that way again it's it's very
interesting but what are your thoughts
of course elon bought twitter yesterday
for what 44 billion dollars bad news for
truth social yeah
true social was bad news from start like
even branding yourself as truth social
it's like the one time like you have
something like go wrong
yeah like the reach like the one time
you have something go wrong on there
just like breaks down the entire brand
being called true social like what what
is that they have a lot of money right
now too and they don't even know what to
do with it they're just like
they got they started this company and
now they're just like i guess we gotta
hire people and have a company have you
have you been on the platform i haven't
even like checked it out no i have not
gone on true cell show but uh danny
the guy who the voice cast with is
always showing me stuff on there the
fact that they call them truths and
re-truths we've been talking about this
a lot because it's just so funny to me
the equivalent of uh
you're getting kicked off because you're
not like you're i don't know actually
hillary shouldn't be in jail they can
kick you off because you're not telling
the truth yeah well i i've seen because
i think they might have opened the
platform to the public i'm sorry if i'm
speaking incorrectly there yeah no but
there's a big waitlist it might be one
of the clunkiest like rollouts of a comp
a social media company in modern history
well i didn't know it was a mess i
didn't know they were called re-truths
but i've seen i think i can get on
because yeah they sent me like hey well
you can skip the line if you want
because they want people on your social
media probably good on twitter i follow
likes like i follow like an array of
journalists for example in summer like
left-leaning and
some of them before even posting on
truth social like they got banned right
away wow like just like i i don't know
the situation i heard a few people get
banned for posting wild like stuff but
not for just connecting i think to like
their twitter profile and then like
people i maybe masks
yeah like they found that they're not
true
they deemed them not a truth teller via
twitter and then yeah it's just
interesting
it was
it's so funny because the whole thing is
that true social is twitter but with the
forbidden fruit of trump right and then
trump's still not on there but he kept
he's basically
saying you know he's gonna make his big
debut right but he and he had some date
he's gonna make it but he's had he
skipped so far he hasn't made his debut
he's still preparing some tweets for it
well what's been interesting about this
elon thing is of course he's using free
speech and
free speech is a term for all americans
under like the constitution but the the
right tense like to like weaponize it
and use it as a buzz term and like
really just like taking elon under their
wing for this and like idolizing him for
this yeah and also they're pushing him
into their wings so it's like it's
happening both right yeah like i don't
know if he claims y'all but
yeah like it's just interesting to see
that
this extreme thing of
elon like on a pedestal now with all
this and
i
he's like there's
probably he's gonna bring back trump i
would assume in the way that trump said
he won't come back really yeah i'm
pretty sure trump well like dude he has
a you know
very uh
they have a lot of money and that's with
that spack i think inspect and it was
like you know i don't know how much they
raised but it was billions i'm pretty
sure and the whole thing hinges on trump
being that's the only place that you get
his information from so i i mean he
would have to not go on there you know
or maybe he says like my
my tweets go on on twitter but like
they're three days later if you want the
if you're on the on the minute it's
going to come from your social well
because it's like he only got a two-year
ban on facebook and instagram so he'll
be back in early 20s oh is that what
they said which is like the worst i
didn't know that i thought it was i
thought it was indefinite yeah no it's
early 2023 for facebook and instagram is
two years which is the worst timing why
banned him at all like for that amount
of time 2023 coming back is like
a big bang for him in terms of like all
the debates and everything start it's
like that's terrible timing
[Music]
it's still funny because people will be
like
uh oh this uh billionaire is gonna
control speech or whatever when i mean
it's just first of all like that's
that's already in the case yeah and then
second of all his whole thing was he
wants to not control speech but i think
that it kind of shows people how much
they the i well
if you're there's some people i just
think are operating from a political bad
faith realm but people that have just
been straight up like brainwashed by all
this nonsense
they're sold that you know elon musk is
going to take over twitter and it's
going to be like
uh
you know a dystopian future of like
just everyone yelling the n word you
can't even go on twitter they're
basically picturing mad max is what
twitter is going to be like you know one
tumbleweed like a guy you know no no one
even has like the guts to go on the mean
streets of twitter because it's
you know
gang violence in the 70s is what you
know so people are in their mind they're
you know if we don't have these bodies
protecting everyone then it's going to
be all mayhem will break loose right
but i my guess is that he's not going to
even
mess with the bullying harassment stuff
as much he's going to be more focused on
uh probably
you know for example you know the
new york post doing the hunter button
laptop stuff and you can talk about it
my guess will be at least at the early
stages that will be kind of the mission
of what he's saying but i don't know i
mean that to me that's
part of what this looks like moving
forward where where everyone says
everything's being forced to be you know
on the table and it is kind of uh where
does this stuff go does it kind of you
end up in a situation where you have
essentially like the free world and then
like the safe world yeah you know do you
have a kind of like a that's very simple
do you have like a you know safety
twitter safety twitter and a safety
netflix where you can put it on you go
you know this is the safe safe version
where i know i'm not gonna potentially
be exposed to any ideas that i think are
bad yeah there's not gonna be any comedy
that says any no no words right that's
or
and everyone else has a free one or does
all of this or the other way that it
happens is
these like two sides fight it up so much
that eventually everyone gets tired of
this whole conversation and it kind of
retracts a little bit back to probably
how it was 10 years ago where your
average person is doesn't feel like
they're involved in a you know political
battle yeah i think you just have to
meet culture where it is too you're
going to have this initial everyone
initially flocked to truth social and
then they realized okay i don't think
that many people are vlogging no no like
well like initially like a bunch of
people were signing up for it and
everything and then they realized okay
this is pretty boring it's just like an
echo chamber well that's all the people
that liked twitter yeah that are
right-wing i know that they you know
right-wing people will be like yeah i
don't want to have my stuff taken down
but more importantly they want to argue
with people
exactly like people
like any
anyone who's really you know political
they go on there to dunk on people and
kind of argue and i think some people
it's not even necessarily bad faith they
actually like it
you know i mean it's not this com
sometimes it's like coming from a place
of hatred i think some people just
actually like arguing about that like
the same way that people
you know me and my friends like to go to
a bar and argue with each other yeah i
think some people see it like that right
they kind of enjoy it and they
little you know [ __ ] disturbers or
whatever so
uh
as far as the other people
will it be unsafe for them it's like you
can already like block people i think
the harassment stuff's not going to
change to a huge degree yeah i think
that elon was saying they want to like
identify i thought authenticity am i
saying that right well that is a factor
that most of the people that are really
saying wild stuff don't have their their
names there but i think that he's i
think that he's wrong about that uh uh i
mean this is a
crazy complicated thing yeah anonymous
stuff like well but yeah but the reason
people
the reason people like twitter is
because they can go there and say stuff
anonymously without getting fired yep
you know and people will be like i know
a lot of commentators will or people
like me that do make stuff we'll kind of
[ __ ] on that and be like well why are
you you know you're not you're a coward
you're anonymous or whatever and i was
like well they don't want to get fired
yeah
you know they'd like i said i've spent a
lot of time designing my life that i
could you know put my opinion out there
without
you know the
tomorrow waking up and i'm out of out of
work and even still is you know risky
business
but for a normal person if you work at
you know the bank and you won't have an
opinion on something like you know
there's a now like i said the the
the entire you know left-wing twitter
was very dedicated to trying to get
people fired for a really long time and
now the right-wing twitter's figured out
how to do that the other way around
so yeah i can imagine why people
wouldn't want to have their name
verified and then say their opinion now
they wake up and they're fired from
their job yeah so also last week the
there was that whole libs of tick tock
situation where yeah washington post put
out an article um libs of libs of
tic-tac-toe elderly woman taylor lauren
um
i think lipstick talk had like what 400k
and now they're up to
probably around 800k just since that
article came out just doubled in
following
crazy it just kind of like did a
mass one who is she talking to right
it's it's one thing if you're talking to
someone that like this is a website that
legitimately uh
shows liberals doing crazy stuff like do
you think there's one person on there
that would care about that article
yeah yeah it's just like
it that one of their fans it's just
their followers it's just gonna it just
literally fueled people that's all it
did yeah it's not like people are like
oh libs have ticked off because it's
like people
it's an echo chamber of itself and
people yeah who aren't outside of it
they're not gonna like see libs of tick
tock and be like oh let's read this dude
a lot of those people yeah a lot of
those people have spent all their time
you know weeding out anyone that's
dissonant from all the jobs and then
they're kind of like we're gonna get you
fired from your jobs we're like what
jobs yeah
no one entertainment has jobs anymore
like everyone's left that system so it i
talked about this a bit on my comedy
special but it really is easier to get
people fired from their you know silicon
valley jobs or their hollywood jobs or
their high profile you know those jobs
have essentially become corporate jobs
where you got to really you know
either try to just be right in line with
what you think the modern pulse of you
know hollywood's opinion on things are
you know what do we think now you know
or you go the other way where you you go
i'm deleting my twitter i'm deleting my
instagram and i'm going to be a movie
star and no one's going to hear from me
about anything
but anyone that wants to be a good
comedian
you know that wants to do stand-up it's
pretty hard to or a podcast it's pretty
hard to have like a
you know speak and put out opinion-based
stuff without you know
stepping on the wrong thing and if you
never step on the wrong thing then it's
like well why would i come to a podcast
to listen to you say the stuff that i
already yeah that's what everyone thinks
well i was hoping for a different
perspective yeah like anonymity and
student student at me are important like
me me on tick tock it was like 2019
there wasn't really people like i'm
older at home with like gen z my friends
weren't on the platform i like yeah i
was first getting comfortable sharing my
opinions online i used like a pseudonym
name but my face was still attached but
i felt comfort on the platform because i
knew like people i didn't know yeah i
knew weren't on it and i mean that's
such a important part of the internet
like yeah exploring just like i don't
know your boundaries and your like your
identity to an extent and definitely
when you're at a certain cultural
relevance like you have to take some
accountability responsibilities i mean
it just is what it is if you yeah if you
have a million subscribers people are
gonna be trying to find out who you are
and someone's gonna uh get to it
someone's gonna figure it out yeah i
just it's probably if you get to a
certain level it's probably yeah it's
very difficult for you to
uh
you know be batman forever without
having your mask taken off in the real
world there's i mean it's just like
there's so many gray areas because i
mean in reality the future and you know
what
zuckerberg talks about with everything
with the metaverse like it's gonna
uplift that that type of approach with
anonymity so much more so it's like
those are important conversations to
have and yet there are so many gray
areas so what are all the different
boundaries there when like i i know at
one point australia was talking about
people having to have their like
driver's license um associated with
their social media accounts do still use
anon names they can still use
pseudonymity but just like in the
background for responsibility purposes
like yeah if you're if you're reported
and all this difference well there's a
solution to this that
is you know a cultural solution that
doesn't require laws telling you that
you have to you know not be anonymous
it's that if everything settled down and
there wasn't insane repercussions then
people wouldn't you know feel like they
are afraid to say their opinion but
currently they are so you know if you
tell them well you have to use your real
name if you want to be on twitter as a
way to like make them behave which is i
guess the purpose of that right you say
people will behave better if they have
to be
uh show their face but
you go
well uh
if
that is like putting an objective
measure on like what behaving better is
if behaving better in the hollywood
sense means you've you know uh
uh have the right opinion on whatever
the new in vogue thing is this you know
news cycle then i think that people are
going to rebel against that and find out
new ways to not uh
have their face attached to their
opinions it also goes hand in hand with
our relationship with work though
because yeah at this point it's like
companies feel like you're
representative of the company's opinions
in a way so if you're putting out
certain opinions like we're going to
push back
but
that relationship is odd and like we
even see with elon like ceos and
being a twitter troll doesn't
necessarily go hand in hand and people
like to push on him a lot for that but
it's just kind of like he's literally
like uh like all my toilet breaks i'm
just tweeting yeah but he's built he's
built his business on uh being able to
like hype up ideas because he has such
you know that's how he was able to
essentially will tesla's you know stock
prices yeah
it's their marketing for sure and like
some degree i mean the bar's still good
is that like a lot of people have that
business model when you're running a
company you got to be the face of it and
but it's like um
to a point now because that that wasn't
traditional like ceos were kind of yeah
like buttoned up not you're not there's
been some probably but it's now you're
seeing like even uh bezos become more
active on twitter slowly but surely
zuckerberg has been like way more active
on instagram like he's been way more
active on instagram lately like i mean
he used to post like maybe once a month
the past week he's been on his stories
every single day he's progressing on
feeds trying to get it out there he's
got a publicity asian yeah it's like
interesting that it's like almost like a
they're like oh they got all this money
but it's like now they want some
cultural relevance because they see like
are undoing it and yeah or they're
seeing the utility of their culture
relatives yeah yeah
it's it's crazy to see and i'm sure that
a lot of these people
uh would probably rather not be posting
other stories but yeah so yeah those
things are i'm sure fairly uh
um
motivated they aren't just like
oh yeah randomly just as gloves are
posting stories now
like that's probably a boardroom meeting
well bezos put out that tweet yesterday
and it was uh quote tweeting some stuff
about tesla and like their relations
with china and different products and he
co-tweeted and i forget the question
exactly wait i have it right here it was
just like um
i need to pull it up so i don't get this
wrong um so yeah they were listing all
of tesla's relationships with china in
terms of the products interesting
question did the chinese government just
gain a bit of leverage over the town
square zinger yeah like and then so he
had that up for like three hours and
then after he posted underneath being
like i mean elon's also good at dealing
with complicated issues
yeah so it's like he was definitely
trying to stir something up a little bit
but then he's like oh my answer is
probably not yeah yeah yeah yeah
he's not ready for this life i've seen
that a million times he's not ready for
that internet fight life
yeah yeah like it's a skill to be able
to handle that stuff oh yeah and it's a
tolerance you develop too right yeah
because just like anything uh
you um the more it happens the more you
know if it's the right amount like if
you're having a swarm of people yelling
at you you're just like oh crap but if
you know just how many followers i have
this is how much is a normal amount and
you're like oh it's only a little bit
higher you can kind of rationalize this
the validity
and what you said how inflammatory who
are the people that are mad at you you
sort of
certainly yeah but you also um
are able to rationalize in your brain
because what drives people's brains
crazy is uh uncertainty right so when
you sort of have a grasp on a little bit
what this looks like i think it's easier
so getting into that game yeah yeah
definitely he's trying to say wild stuff
and he goes i mean actually i'm not i'm
not ready for this life
but
um i think that
he
he's doing the same thing because he
owns the washington post so i mean
this is it's kind of all of twitter
right now it's just everyone hoping that
their billionaire is going to like save
the day for them yeah just everyone
flocking to their building except that
they've never been yeah
gates bezos zuck like good at the
internet i feel like in terms of no but
they're yeah they're
i think you you uh said an interesting
thing too that it does it is interesting
that you have a whole like generation of
people that kind of uh
that are that love the idea that people
are like such a slave to their company
that even what they tweet they should be
fired for like the whole idea of
everyone should be fired for everything
is so
antithetical to like i care about
workers rights and everything like that
which is probably what so much of you
know modern cultures moved away from
actually caring about any uh
you know your average person that just
like has a job and
has to you know go to work and raise a
family or whatever
[Music]
wall street journal put out an article
this week it's a how long new hires are
expected to stay at their current job um
people 18 to 24. it's like 70 or 2 years
or less and in the past years it's of
course been like five or more years and
also vox put out an article uh
yesterday basically a buzz term that
people used a lot i would say back in
2020s like gen z does not dream of labor
one of the quotes they used was uh do
you work i don't have goals i don't have
ambition i only want to be attractive
i'm like that's probably not the best
like use of like there's an actual
argument there and then like you're
you're you're going to use that quote i
only want to be that's just yeah sort of
like modern and internet like nihilism
for show yeah for it just goes into all
that too because
just the the personal relationship with
work oh you want to feel like a family
you want to feel like a team which is
important like work is of course an
important aspect of like your schedule
and it's a huge part of your life hours
wise um but then there's this weird
relationship if you have people just
pushing back on like okay what am i
actually here for just okay maybe to
make money and uh
maybe just a lot of the work i do feels
robotic
it's it's a bizarre
thing to see unfold it sort of relates
back to what we
were you know kind of touched on at the
beginning though where
you know there's there's a it's easy
it's one thing to diagnose a problem and
then
you know
what people want to do about it is a
very different thing because i actually
very much
agree that there is like a bad deal for
young people and or you know millennials
and maybe uh i think gen x are learning
from it a little bit yeah and uh or gen
z you're sorry gen z i was like
yeah it is it is like a bad deal and i
mean on a purge so on like
there's like what do you do on society
and want to do it on an individual like
on an individual level
i would definitely not want to i would
never tell i would say that if you're
a person that has aspirations you
probably shouldn't enter like a
workforce that seems hostile to you
where the deal doesn't seem to make
sense like the whole package doesn't
really make sense right to go to school
and
but it will for some people i mean
certain people are overachievers and
you're going to succeed wherever but
then you go what is your average person
like
so if you want to do something great i
think that it's a better time than ever
to be able to sort of exit the
exit the mainstream of the workforce
and
the cost is actually lower in a lot of
ways because from before let's say here
okay so if you want to be a doctor
or a
you know work at ibm or whatever
or like maybe you want to be a
contractor whatever the standard i could
probably name off even more jobs
just keep
going if you want to do one of those
jobs right but if you want to leave you
go well then what right it's kind of the
cost is high to like tell your family or
your even your parents when you're young
i'm not gonna it feels like a higher
cost whereas now
you could you could do that and just go
i'm gonna go deliver food for a second
you know when i feel like i'll do uber
for a second i'll do
maybe some other things so
and it's not as crazy so i think the
rewards lower for a lot of traditional
careers and the and the moving away from
it is lower uh to sort of try something
different so on that side it is i can
see why if you're 22 and you go to just
finish school and you have some job you
don't get paid that much you can't
really afford that good of a house
you know because everything's so
expensive you feel like you're getting
work to the bone and then yeah i feel
like you're just working for what like
just to keep working and then on top of
that you see
the uh you see the alternative to that
in your face non-stop
so it's not just okay well this is kind
of what it is and we're all dealing it's
like no i know lots of people that you
know uh
have that's why every dude's trying to
be a crypto guy because you know you've
seen that that's a better life whatever
that's why everyone's trying to day
trade or trying to everyone that's out
there people are doing travel vlogs in
the rich you know what i mean there's
girls that are getting naked on only
fans and now they make 200 grand a year
and that's not even that outs out crazy
right yeah so to a lot of people you go
that's a better life available but
it's it's only a better life available
if you're the type of person that can
kind of motivate yourself and be an
alternative lifestyle so for some people
even though that's attractive they
couldn't do it so it's actually just
making them sadder so then
now so that's the whole problem i guess
so for some people
their idea of what the solution was is
the government i guess would step in and
you know give them money right and i
think that you guys probably talk a lot
about that or
you know
but to me there might be something to be
said about
the i always think of you know like the
student loan thing none of the answers
here but if i with the student loans
right a lot of people took a you know
100 grand to get an arts degree that's
useless right
one
obvious thing that will happen is if
anyone who grew up and watched their mom
do that or their dad do that won't do
that
like anyone who
whose parents right now you know they're
14 and their dad is 80 grand of debt and
he works some normal job from university
they're not going to do that so there's
an entire generation of people that
probably are you know so that's already
being affected which
you know
the same way that all this stuff's
happening is probably moving a lot of
those people away from the workforce and
creating new things and creating a new
world but it's always i think that's
probably what you guys talk about and i
i think i respect a lot of the stuff you
say but there is always that like hey
how much short-term pain happens uh for
you know potentially a better solution
in the future and then how does that
pain get distributed yep and i guess
that's kind of the fundamental
question of where you sit you know what
i mean no i love that point because
that's something i say all the time is
sometimes like initial huge movements
are necessary to start like
conversations about stuff but then in
reality to like you're saying sometimes
like
time is truly what heals it there's
going to be generations where like that
they have this stain on them and they're
just like stuck in a mindset and like
whatever but as culture changes and yeah
as younger generations observe something
um it's just like funnels and like as
they grow sometimes it takes a
generation sometimes i mean
you know think about how
i mean i'm not the only one that would
be talking about this stuff but just i
can probably name the three things that
i'm the most a part of because if i look
at how this manifested in my personal
life but the biggest one let's say just
comedy there was a time where you know
in 2015 2016 where everything was sort
of changing a lot of these networks are
making bad choices and comedians like me
were just like there's no place for me
to be part of this right and a lot of
people were kind of saying you know
there was a time when you could kind of
work through this system so what i spend
25 years being 20 years being a comedian
you try to take these writing jobs now
you can't even make money and you're not
even getting jobs and basically there's
a dead-end path and not that you should
ever be owed a career in [ __ ] being
famous but like that is what people said
it basically took four years to sort
itself out
where all of those people left the
industry and now everyone's kind of
making money selling tickets and running
their own business that happened in four
years that's wild where all of those
people that were you know trying to get
writing jobs and trying to pitch you
know sitcoms
now all of those like
enormous cohort of those people have
left a new industry's emerged and that
was in four years it went from
uh late night being the biggest thing in
the world to joe rogan's the biggest
thing running a podcast in his basement
in
a very very short period of time so i
mean it might feel long but sometimes
it's short but then again four years is
like that
right so then and then on the other side
maybe there is you know sometimes when
we're talking about
these things i mean
maybe on my lone thing like this has
become a popular conversation there's a
lot of people you know the james aldrich
is the world i'm sure like guys like
that are like yo don't go to college
this doesn't make sense so maybe that is
changing things and but
uh there's also forces working the other
way that are saying actually we should
make it easier and the government should
pay more of it and that'll probably push
so i don't know it's a everything's
going in uh
a fight that's taking place at the same
time so i'm like i don't necessarily
know
uh which one of those things is the best
i mean
and it's yeah i guess you could
it all boils down to that like who gets
the pain and how much of it is there and
can you as a society take that hmm yeah
well
epic and insight and like i think one
last thing because i wanted that to be
the last thing but i find this really
interesting uh mark zuckerberg put out
it was an article i think new york times
yesterday that meta is opening uh like
in-person stores now for their virtual
reality and uh ar glasses full circle
yeah full circle now in person stores
all stuff have you tried virtual reality
isn't that the best yeah
that's right i think that uh like
amazon i think was talking about that
too recently or whatever and it was just
like they basically took yeah what if we
take stores and put them online and it's
like what if there was an online store
but it was like at a location or like
uber having taxis now like all this
different stuff it's like i love it
but that's what i mean it always is just
you know unpackaging everything
and then building it i always think that
in my own life that there's so many
times that i do need to break stuff down
so i really try to build on things that
make sense right but sometimes you just
end up built on too many faulty things
and then you just have to like break it
all down and kind of build it up again
better so a lot of times it is just that
where they
uh they just like how cds used to be
sold right there was they had uh
everyone sold cds and then the
those market clearing houses are like
here's the eight cds they bundled them
back up then they sort of uh they got
rid of that and then they sort of
decentralized it again back to you know
the napsters and the apple music of the
world and then they basically now had
spotify where you pay a service and then
you bundled all them together it just
keeps on bundling and bundling i'm also
moving back to like hotels instead of
airbnb's half the time because airbnb is
all the different fees and it's also
just easier to book a hotel yeah yeah
you don't have to clean up after
yourself like you have to deal with the
person yeah it's just like yeah full
circle but have you tried virtual
reality okay so i tried virtual reality
i've tried um
i i i don't know uh there's probably
lots of different versions but i have
tried the one where you put the helmet
on yeah and uh
you know walk around and stuff like that
how have you liked it i'm just
interested to hear you i'm very
skeptical of mark zuckerberg's vision of
the utility of this immediately so i get
the idea of you know like let's say zoom
meetings everyone's doing that right now
right that happened very quickly where
that was and i get that and you go okay
but what if you put the glasses on and
it feels like you're together and i was
like i want to be zoned out in a lot of
meetings i don't want to be like yeah
i'm on a whiteboard yeah i just it's the
same reason why
uh
a lot of times i don't want people call
me and i'm like you can send a text you
know what i mean it's not so i i don't
really see the utility outside of like
gaming and fun yeah which i do see a
huge like mark and i see a big uh
you know there's
but i guess to me it seems like at its
core mark zuckerberg wants to own like
the crypto marketplace or at least you
know
uh be able to sort of
uh make money off of the crypto
marketplace is really the goal
underneath it all but so as far as i
i've it's very
i still don't get it you go okay you
could go on a date with someone i guess
or like you give me
are you like a real life
usefulness of the of the metaverse it's
not a real life usefulness
what what is what i think it's literally
just pitch it to me what would i i'm not
pitching it because i'm not about it you
don't really see it like i mean i see
like what he's trying to do but i'm not
like which is what what is what is the
real life usefulness of it it's just
like going to be a parallel to reality
but something so much more interesting
like think about like you could
subscribe to like almost like a day in
the life of like your favorite survivor
celebrities all of these things are just
fun right yeah i don't go on vacation i
don't do i
write and do comedy and podcast and then
i go to stand up at night it's like i
don't do anything else but think like
social media it's like the next level of
just like an immersive version of social
media like
like
yeah social media it's fun but it's also
like a lot yeah i can see that but again
you're still talking about entertainment
so
all of the things that i see is useful
are just entertainment yeah i agree yeah
so i don't see any you know real value
outside of that other than listen my
family lives in a different place um
so if you know i could see that us doing
like a meeting up yeah a meet up but
again that's you know
very small you know we did a zoom thing
it's kind of cool i can also talk to my
mom on the phone yeah it's not you know
the end of the world but but yeah the i
don't do any of that stuff but i guess i
could see what you're saying where well
what if instead of watching your
favorite creator doing a tick-tock dance
it feels like
you're watching her do something in her
house but it feels like you're in the
house or something right
yeah that's that's a weird but right i
guess so it feels like someone's
watching our podcast but it feels like
they're watching it from that chair like
sitting there yeah yeah yeah and i see
that so
in the same way that they've talked
about being able to do you know online
comedy clubs and stuff like that and
maybe it will but again i i don't see
the real life application outside of
entertainment
and
slight conveniences like i guess if you
had the glasses on now i'm rambling but
if you if you have the glasses on and
instead of having two computers i could
have five computers and it sort of
stores places
you know from uh maybe there's like a
workflow thing that makes it easier i
don't know i mean it's like i don't like
to wear the i don't know where the glass
is yeah like i think to be honest
to be honest it's just about like
stimulation at the end of the day like i
don't do anything
i know that's what i'm saying like
people like the reality of what virtual
reality is going to end up being is just
like max stimulation still stimulates
people the most probably uh hanging out
with their friends and having sex
so i mean go touch grass yeah yeah i
mean that's like legitimately
well um i think one last point too do
you find interesting you'll have to like
watch this interview with it's with tim
ferriss and mark zuckerberg recently he
was just talking about how people will
be able to build like oh no i listened
to tim ferriss or zuckerberg's on a
different one but yeah he's probably
maybe yeah it was that one yeah he was
just talking about yeah people will be
able to build like their own governments
almost like their own towns i'm just
like
yeah yeah well yeah i understand the
like nft application and that's that's
where i can see why
businesses are trying to like grab this
space i do get the idea of you know
building this land and owning it and
inside the metaverse i mean i've already
that already always existed in games
forever right you know you have these
swords that you own right there is
property in in the like
virtual world already but
as far as uh
people owning their own cities
i guess
well
then what you just live in the city and
you never come out to the real world
because it's still it's
if i live here and that is essentially
one of two things one
is it's like a back to entertainment yep
or two it's like my like weekend home
like it's like a getaway
so it's like a cottage
so you have a cottage but instead of
the cottage being on a lake you put a
helmet on
and the cottage exists in the virtual
world
maybe i don't know i think it's
my prediction
is that
people have been talking about ai and vr
for a really long time
and while other things
like we said tick tock didn't exist what
four or five years ago well musically's
been around for almost 10 years but yeah
went from you know no one heard of it to
the number one thing that kids use or
whatever right
ar and vr i've been hearing about you
know like 30 years stacks and
uh ipos and
big investments from lots of companies
and people going into space if you're
into this the space not space i've been
hearing about that forever
yet i've seen zero
application change in terms of
normal human life they haven't even been
able to make 3d movies watchable yeah
like
they've yet to make 3d movie movies
anything anyone wants to see
i'll see it yeah i've still been stumped
stubborn i haven't even tried like a vr
headset yet it's the same way i am with
gaming like i i watch twitch like here
and there but so i'm like i know what's
going on in like the game world and like
i know how games are playing stuff but
i'm like i'm just following them when
anyone follows any other creatures yeah
i feel like i i know i'd get hooked so
i'm like i'm not even gonna game like i
i just like it's kind of a boundary
thing and but it's just weird because
let's say yeah at meta they're
definitely going to start incorporating
the next five years like into their work
day these headsets and like
them wanting to yeah
let's do these meetings
through vr or whatever i get the
workplace used for it yeah it's just
like
i'm interested to see the boundaries
that are gonna have happen there between
like what if someone doesn't wanna
be involved in vr stuff at all and like
within workplaces if that becomes a
mainstream situation like can people be
like i don't know are there gonna be
workplaces they're like no we do not
yeah i guess it becomes a productivity
thing like imagine you know we're doing
a zoom meeting at work and i have this
paper and i'm able to just go you know
the way that you kind of swipe your
phone i'm able to go oh yeah and then it
just kind of comes up on your screen
what i mean i don't know it's all it's
all ver everything that i can think of
is very
minutia productivity oriented which i do
care about but it's it's not
this is in my opinion a
minor improvement of the of of
everyone's day-to-day life yeah i think
we're on the same page but thank you for
being here working everyone yeah where
can everyone find you again what's your
like social the boys cast with ryan long
every friday
and that is my podcast it's on youtube
and itunes
and all the other places and uh i do a
sketch every
week every monday at youtube.com ryan
long comedy and all my social media
handles are at ryan long comedy hey all
right thank you it was great talking
thank you